[संगीत]
हेलो गैस व्हाट'एस अप मैं ए गया हूं
फ्रॉम
सिक्योरिटी
के बड़े में
जाओगे
तो अब अपन आगे बढ़ते हैं इसके अंदर
ओके
रीस्टार्ट करेंगे
तो हेलो गैस मैं हूं हार्दिक आशीर्वाद फिर
से ए गया हूं अपना डेट 3 लेकर पाइथन का जो
अपने कैप्सूल कोड से फ्रॉम डिफरेंट
सिक्योरिटी
तो अभी 2 मिनट के थोड़ा रुकना पड़ा था
क्योंकि इतने जान नहीं आए थे बट हां अभी
लगता था
अपन आगे बढ़ते हैं सो आ कल का अगर किसी को
रिवीजन चाहिए हो तो आप अभी चाट में लिख दो
मुझे की तन में इसका रिवीजन करवा दो या
कुछ भी तो पर मैं कल का 10 मिनट के
ग्रीनविजन के लिए अलग से निकाल दूंगा
स्टार्टिंग
में लिख देना तब तक के लिए मैं आगे स्टडीज
पढ़ना हूं की डिक्शनरी होते क्या है जैसा
मैंने वादा किया था जो लोग दे वन में थे
लोगों ने देखा होगा टेबल के अंदर के यहां
स्टडी का दे है
तो वो जाके दे वन देख सकते हैं
कलेक्शन करते डाटा
नहीं रख सकते हैं
डुप्लीकेट वैल्यू रख सकते थे
ओके
हां तो पहले डिस्कस करेंगे
अगर अपन पाइथन 3.7 के पीछे जाएंगे तो इसके
अंदर ये उन ऑर्डर राहत था
और अगर अपन पैठण 3.7 या उससे आगे जाएंगे
तो ये ऑर्डर होने ग गया मतलब इस वे में
आता है
इसको अपन आगे इसके बड़े में देखेंगे की इस
वाव में लिखा होता है क्या कैसा राहत है
अभी इसके अंदर सो यही होता है डिक्शनरी
कुछ नहीं बस की वैल्यू पर्स है और कुछ सीन
नहीं है की राहत है एक वैल्यू राहत है
उसकी से चीज होती है आगे अपन देखेंगे की
क्या चीज होती है और डिस्टेंस के साथ-साथ
आज अपना देखेंगे ऑपरेटर के बड़े में
तो क्या होता है अपने कुछ नहीं होते बस ये
एक अपना ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करने के लिए कम
आते हैं और बस सिंपल सा ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म
करने वाली चीज ऑपरेटर सिंपल ऑपरेशन ऑपरेटर
ऑपरेशन
परफॉर्म करती है वो चीज अपना ऑपरेटर
है अपना असाइनमेंट ऑपरेटर है कंपैरिजन
ऑपरेटर है लॉजिकल ऑपरेटर है
मेंबरशिप ऑपरेटर है
इसको अगर अपने पास टाइम बचेगा तो उसके बाद
अपन देखेंगे
सो अभी लोगों ने कहा था की उनको रिवीजन
चाहिए अपना 10 मिनट का तो अभी 835 हो रहा
है सो वो डिवीजन चला है अपना तो आइडल में
खोल लेट हूं
अपना फाइल में जाएंगे न्यू फाइल में
जाएंगे
प्लीज चाट में लिख दो कौन सा लिस्ट है
की आप लोग मतलब कितना अच्छे से मैं पढ़ा
का रहा हूं बेसिकली की आपको मतलब रिवीजन
भी कर रहे हैं की नहीं या फिर मैं इतना
अच्छा बड़ा रहा हूं की आपको रिवीजन की
जरूर ही नहीं पद रही है
सो प्लीज मुझे चाट में लिखकर बता दो की
कौन सा लिस्ट है कौन सा है बाकी मैं यहां
पर टाइप तो प्रिंट कर देता हूं
और जिन लोगों को नहीं समझ में आया है की
कौन सा लिस्ट है पहले डोंट वारी में अभी
वापस से बताऊंगा की कैसे मैं आईडेंटिफाई
कर पे कौन सा लिस्ट है
कैसे कर पाएंगे
अरे पेरेंट्स इसके अंदर राहत है वो अपना
राहत है टप्पल
ठीक है सिंपल
एक बार
तो अपन वैल्यू को किस कैसे करते हैं किसी
भी अपना
लिस्ट से
यहां से ऐसा करना है की इंटरप्रेटर को रीड
ना करें बट यह लाइन यहां पर रहे तो मैं इस
लाइन को क्या करूं
और कैसे करो
इस लाइन को
क्या करूं
कमेंट
ओके
चलेगा
कोई अपने फोर ए जाएगा
की नहीं कारी है या करें है तो कुछ एरर
आया हो या कुछ दिक्कतें का दुविधा कुछ भी
आई हो तो फिर कमेंट में यहां पे लिखो ताकि
मैं उसको दूर कर सुकून
थैंक यू हर्ष भाई बताने के लिए
चलो
इसके अंदर हां
मतलब
करनी होगी तो मैं इसको कैसे करूंगा
से ही है
हां यह देखो अपना 5 से लेकर मैंने कहा वन
तक जाएंगे तो उसके लिए ऐसे नेगेटिव कारी
जाति है अगर आप लोग सोचते थे की मैं ऐसा
आगे वन लिख के फिर करूंगा तो होगा वो तो
वैसा वहां पर इस कैसे में नहीं होता है
इसके लिए अगर मैं इसको चाहे तो रिवर्स चला
सकता हूं इसके आगे अपन यहां पे ऐसे लगा के
अगर मैं इसको माइंस वन कर डन यहां पर
तो इसे रिवर्स में जाता है यहां से यह
उल्टा जाएगा
की एक चीज मैंने आपको नहीं बताई है इसके
अलावा ट्राई करके आना वो चीज यही थी आपका
मैंने होमवर्क इधर ही कर दिया है सिंपल सा
था कुछ ऐसे ऊपर नीचे नहीं था इसके अंदर तो
आगे मैं इसके अंदर लिस्ट के अंदर अपना
चीजें एड करता हूं
इसके अंदर एक को मैं आगे जाके सिर्फ
प्रिंट करूंगा
लिस्ट के अंदर
किसी भी चीज को
करता है
तो मैंने इसको कमेंट कर दिया है
तो अपने यहां से फूल है गया पॉप की कोई
स्पेशल मुझे बताया चाट के अंदर तब बताऊंगा
थोड़ा सा आगे बाढ़ लेट हूं
समझ में नहीं ए रहा है
समझ में नहीं ए रहा है भाई आप बताएंगे
प्लीज क्योंकि
यह चीज वही है जो लास्ट क्लास में कराई गई
थी
इससे कुछ एडवांस नहीं है
है की डिक्शनरी क्या होती है
ठीक है तो मैंने इसे बताया की डिक्शनरी
सपना की वैल्यू पर से
दिखता है
तो यहां पर
ठीक है
डिक्शनरी का यह जैसे मेरे जैसे लोगों को
डिक्शनरी की पुरी स्पेलिंग नहीं आई है तो
यहां डिस्टिक यह पाइथागोरस्य लिखा तो यह
डिश है
इसके अंदर क्या होता है ना की क्या होता
है वैल्यू क्या होता है वो अभी मैं आपको
इसके सामने दिखता हूं की कौन सा ये होता
है कौन सा वैल्यू होता है ठीक है
इतना तो मुझे भी कोई आइडिया है कलर्स नहीं
ए रहा है क्यों नहीं ए रहा है बट ठीक है
अपना चीज कम करेगा
तो यह जो पर क्रिएट हुआ है यह डिक्शनरी
क्रिएट हुआ है ठीक है अब डिस्टिक के अंदर
की क्या है वैल्यू क्या है बताना
जो भी कहते हैं तो इस तरफ जो राहत है ना
इसका ये होता है अपना की और इस तरह होता
है अपना वैल्यू ठीक
हो या कुछ भी हो यहां पर अगर वे वेरिएबल
नहीं है तो आपको ये ऐसा लगाना पड़ेगा साइन
मतलब अपना ये तो पोस्ट लगाते हैं सिंगल
कोड है डबल को डबल लगाते हैं और लगाना
पड़ेगा
यहां पर ऐसे कोड लगाना पड़ेगा या फिर अगर
नॉर्मली कोई नंबर है तो नंबर भी चला है
मतलब अपन इसके अंदर की वैल्यू पर के अंदर
की होता है ना वो या कोई भी नंबर हो सकता
है या कोई भी अल्फाबेट हो सकता है
कुछ भी र सकता है वैल्यू कुछ भी र सकता है
क्या इसके अंदर की जो वैल्यू होती है ना
वैल्यू अपना है ना कोई भी ट्रैवल आइटम भी
हो सकता है ये ट्रैवल आइटम के हिसाब से जो
मैंने कल बताया था की ट्रैवल रहते हैं
अपना लिस्ट सब सेट
ट्रैवल नहीं है
की
यह इसके मतलब
ठीक है
अंडरस्टैंड
करके लिखोगे ना अपना तो वो एक मेथड आता है
लेकिन वो एक मेथड है अपना उसके साथ जो
लगता है लेकिन एक फंक्शन अगर अपन कल करते
हैं तो फंक्शन अपना लेने ही है
ठीक है
तो अब देखो अब मैंने इसके अंदर मैंने ना
एक कम करता हूं यहां पर लिखना हूं अपना
इसको थोड़ा ना अच्छी तरीके से बनाता हूं
मैं की जैसे यहां लिखना हूं ये अपना अपना
मां लो ये अपने
आगे लिखना हूं
ठीक है
तो इस समय कलर दाल देता हूं अपना
व्हाइट
[संगीत]
ज्यादा आइडिया
यह अपने स्ट्रिंग है इसको
किसी भी डिक्शनरी
नहीं है उसे कैसे में यहां पर बताइए
डिक्शनरी
मैं इसके अंदर ही एक और बार लिखना हूं
यहां पर मॉडल
और मॉडल
अब अगर मैं इस कर को प्रिंट करूंगा
चेंज कर दिया था
अरे अरे
ये चीज
इस कैसे में यहां पर क्या हो रहा है
एग्जांपल
तो डिक्शनरी थोड़ा हार्ड गैस इतना भी नहीं
है अगर एक बार आप समझ लोग तो कोई सीन नहीं
है
बट डिस्टर्ब
यही वैल्यू लिख ले तो वो भी हो सकता है
इसके अंदर
जैसे यहां पर यह मॉडल अपने आप से डाला तो
फिर ऐसे सीन ए गया अब अपन यहां पे क्या कर
सकते हैं ना अगर अपन को ऐसा ही कुछ जानना
है की एक ही खाने पर दो वालुज वगैरा डालनी
है तो मैंने इसका लिस्ट बनाता है यहां पर
जैसे मैंने स्टार्टिंग में कहा था की अपन
इसके साथ मैंने कुछ भी डाटा पर लगा सकते
हैं की के साथ में
वैल्यू कोई भी टाइप हो सकता है चला है
इसको सब कुछ
तो यहां पर मैं लिखूंगा
प्लीज चाट बता दो किलो का समझ में ए रहा
है की लोग के ऊपर से जा रहा है की उसे
रिकॉर्डिंग में और देखो मतलब और डिटेलिंग
से इसको बताओ
समझ में ए रहा है
मॉडल लिखा मैंने कहा की यहां पर आगे
नहीं चाहिए उसे कैसे में मैं अब क्या
करूंगा उसे कैसे में मैं करूंगा की अपना
देखो क्या हुआ ना इतना तक अपना कम कर रहा
था ना यहां तक डिक्शनरी
क्या किया इसने एक वैल्यू के तोर पर लिस्ट
दिया अपने को यह पार्ट ने वैल्यू के तोर
पर क्या दिया यह वाला लिस्ट दिया
तो अब इसका डाटा अपना लिस्ट हो गया अब अगर
ये लिस्ट हो गया तो मैं इस आइटम को एक्सेस
करने के लिए सीधा कुछ नहीं करूंगा बस इसका
इंडेक्स दाल दूंगा जिससे मेरे को यह सीधा
अपना आइटम लिखकर ए जाएगा
तो हमें केवल लिखूंगा
सॉरी यहां पर टाइप का टाइप करेगा
डिक्शनरी के अंदर मुझे एक नया की और एक
नया वैल्यू
कीजिए कंपनी
कंपनी
तो देखो अपना यह मॉडल भी ए गया इसके अंदर
यह ए गया अपने इंजन यहां पर
पेट्रोल कलर
दाल दिया है
मां लो अपने एमपी डिक्शनरी है उसके
स्टार्टिंग में तो मैंने करके दिखाए था
अपना कुछ बस नॉर्मल ही है ये काली ब्रीड्स
खोल बैंड करके दिखाए था मैंने
हां तो उसके थ्रू अपना
अपना वालुज भी दाल सकते हैं इस मेथड के
थ्रू की वैल्यू
जैसे मैंने बताया की इसके लिस्ट भी डालता
है कुछ भी डालता है कोई जो माजिद डालो
गियर से इनपुट लेकर डालो कैसे भी डालो जो
मर्जी करना कर सकते हैं
है इसके अंदर यह इंजन वाला चीज को यह
पेट्रोल ने मेरी गाड़ी डीजल वाली है तो
अगर मैं यहां पर इंजन में अगर मुझे
पेट्रोल करना है तो मैं अप्प क्या लिखूंगा
की इंजन
तो देखो यहां पर इंजन में पेट्रोल की जगह
पर डीजल लिख कर ए गया है
कंपनी एड नहीं किया यह अपना ओरिजिनल है
अपना ठीक है
इंडियन करके ले लिया
उसके अंदर
उसे नहीं करते इसको सीरियसली
उसे करता हूं
मतलब डीटेल्स
ठीक है
अपने पास अवेलेबल
तो यह अपने डॉट किया
जाता है
लिस्ट लिख देना पड़ता है
इसको बोलते
हैं
डिक्शनरी के अंदर है की नहीं
वह चीज चेक करने के लिए अपन क्या सिंपल से
इस्तेमाल करेंगे की
मॉडल और कर
ट्रू
अगर
ट्राई करोगे तो नहीं होगा
तो पीटर्स भी अपन अच्छे से करेंगे
अगर मां लो की अगर अपन को
सब चीजों
डालते हैं एक और भी तरीका है डाटा को
अपडेट करने का डालने का इस चीज के अलावा
यहां पर लिखेंगे
आफ्टर चेंज
बिफोर चेंज अपना मॉडल वेन्यू ठीक है
सो यही चीज अपना राहत है उसके अंदर
कार्ड अपडेट के अंदर लेकिन इतना झंझट नहीं
करते हैं बस सीधा वैसे ही कर लेते हैं
जिससे अपन करते हैं इजी भी लगता है यह कौन
इतने फंक्शन वगैरा पहले बहुत जब बड़े-बड़े
प्रोग्राम करेंगे तो बहुत से अपने मॉडल्स
वगैरा दिमाग में राहत है अपना मेथड जो
करें
नॉर्मली वैसे कर लेते हैं कार्डबोर्ड
अपडेट करता है लोग उसे नहीं करते बट हां
अभी भी उसे करते हैं
तो कैसे करेंगे अपन जैसे कर
डॉट
अपना
इसके साथ ही राहत है
थोड़ा अलग तो अच्छा रहेगा
पैटर्न मैजिक
आप लोग
डिक्शनरी
अपना यहां पर अपना डिक्शनरी
इतने में खत्म नहीं होता है ठीक है बट और
भी देखना बाकी 90% इधर मैं खत्म हो गया है
केवल आगे वाले लेक्चरर्स में और देखेंगे
कल के लेक्चर कुछ ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है कल
का जरूर ट्रेड करना है
हमने भाई लोग को भी का देना अटेंड करने को
अब आते हैं
अपने अपने
रहते हैं वही रहते हैं
प्लस 25
को डिवाइस
क्या करता है ना यह रिमाइंडर
अपनाया आउटपुट में आएगा
प्रोग्रामिंग करने के बाद तो इतना भी गंदा
बैंड कर दिया कैलकुलेटर
बताओ
लिंकडइन की कमेंट के अंदर दाल रहे हैं या
टेलीग्राम पे मस्त एक्टिव से दिखे रहे हैं
और टेलीग्राम पे हमको बता रहे हैं की हां
जो टैक्स दिए गए हैं वो टास्क करेगा करेगा
सारे नोट करके दिए गए थे और हमारी टीम जो
है वो सब कुछ देख रही है सबको मॉनिटर का
रही है की कौन-कौन क्या-क्या कर रहा है
कैसे कर रहा है तो उन लोग को ही मिलेगा ये
पीपीटी मेरी या फिर कोई भी फाइल तुम
क्योंकि तुम एग्जांपल के साथ में फिर से
माना कर दूंगा
अगर तुम्हारा इंगेजमेंट दिखेगा तो भी अगर
आगे अच्छा लगता है और कम करने के लिए
तो इंगेजिंग बना भाई एकदम सब कुछ मिलेगा
थ्री का स्क्वायर
भी कर सकते हैं मतलब जिन लोगों को गणित
अपने अच्छी करनी हो तो कट करके गणित अच्छी
कर लो
स्टार स्टार
तो ये ट्रू हो जाएगा
इसके अंदर
ठीक है
ठीक है अभी मैं इसको भी कमेंट कर देता हूं
तो अपना आता है
लॉजिकल ऑपरेटर
नहीं है
[संगीत]
क्या यहां पर यहां पर चेक करें
छोटा है
ना की ये क्या हो रहा है क्या नहीं है
इस चीज को ठीक है तो अपन ने यहां पे चेक
किया की यार ये इससे छोटा तो है यहां पे
अपना और का कम
दोनों ट्रू है
ठीक है
अगर मैं यहां पर
क्योंकि इस कैसे में क्या हुआ ना ये वाली
जो कंडीशन थी कंडीशन
यमुना
नगर
दोनों में से कोई भी एक ट्रू हो जाता है
तो दिखा देगा
दोनों में से कोई एक भी ट्रू या दोनों ही
ट्रू है तो ही ट्रू दिखा देगा
दोनों में से कोई एक भी ट्रू है तो ट्रू
दिखाएगा यह और के कैसे में है की और
ठीक है इन दोनों में से कोई भी अगर एक
ट्रू है तो ट्रू दिखा देगा अगर दोनों में
से अगर दोनों ही जल हो तो जल दिखाएगा तब
एक ही कंडीशन में फर्स्ट दिखाएगा ये और
अपना जब दोनों ही जल है और और अपना सिर्फ
एक ही कंडीशन में मतलब और अपना सिर्फ एक
ही कंडीशन में ट्रू दिखाएगा जब दोनों ही
ट्रू है यह चीज देखनी पड़ेगी समझनी पड़ेगी
ठीक है
लौट क्या किया
बिट्टू
वह लिख देना
इतना भी अपना को भूलने में रिजल्ट दिखाएगा
तो इसका भी नोट आगे लगाओगे तो उल्टा कर
देगा कोई भी बुलियन रिजल्ट का नोट उल्टा
कर देगा उसको बस इतना ही नोट का कम है
लेक्चर अपन है इसमें बहुत ज्यादा ठीक है
ठीक है
जिंदगी में राहत है जो अपने जो उसका
बॉयफ्रेंड सही होने के बाद भी उसको एकदम
गलत प्रूफ कर देगा ये नोट बेस्ट फ्रेंड है
भाई
ठीक है
गलत कंडीशन को ट्रू कर देता है
की यार तुम बताओ ना उसके दिल में हो की
नहीं तो यह अपना यह
कहा है
की नहीं
तो क्या बिगन इनके पास की भाई मैं हूं की
नहीं चेक करो
हां वही तो उसके दिल में बस हुआ है उसने
ठीक है
इसके अंदर मतलब हां
ये इसके अंदर वो नोट का भी से कम है ये भी
इसको उल्टा कर देगा जल दिखा देगा जो इसका
ट्रू आया था की भाई नहीं है क्या ये जाएगा
इसके पास नोट इनके पास में ये भाई बताओ ना
मैं उसके लिस्ट में नहीं हूं क्या फल
नहीं हूं क्या
अपना क्या था आज का टारगेट
करो अपना शरीर के अंदर और ये सारे अपडेट्स
आपको करके बताने हैं और करके बताने के बाद
मैं आपको इन सब को अपने लाइन कहना है
वहां पर आपको
सॉरी सॉरी
ऐसे फैशन तू का आया है जैसे पैटर्न थ्री
का भी पोस्ट आएगा उसे पोस्ट के अंदर आपको
कमेंट में जो टैक्स दिया गया है यह आपका
टैक्स नंबर वन है आपको ट्राई करना आपको
डिक्शनरी के साथ में और भी अगर उसके कोई
मेथड से तो वो भी यहां पर आप कमेंट में
डालो साथ के लिए ऑपरेटर सारे ट्राई करके
उसका कोड हो या स्क्रीनशॉट हो जो मर्जी वो
यहां पे कमेंट में दाल दो कमिटमेंट में
डालने के साथ में आपको पहले अपना
टेलीग्राम से टेलीग्राम चैनल को भी जॉइन
कर लेने का है सारे लिंक आपको इस वीडियो
के डिस्क्रिप्शन के अंदर नहीं तो पिछले
किसी भी वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन के अंदर
आपको हमारे सारे हैंडल्स के लिंक मिल
जाएंगे वहां जाएंगे स्कैन कर दो पूरा अगर
आपको अच्छा लगता है वही बताओ बड़ा लगता है
तो वो भी बताओ जैसे भी आपके रिव्यूज होते
हैं सारे रिव्यूज आपके एक्सेप्टेड है किसी
भी चीज के बड़े में हमारे कंपनी का जो भी
चीज है अपना टूल वूल भी होगा कुछ रिलेशन
है सब कुछ हम लोग एक्सेप्ट करते हैं सब
कुछ नहीं है की भाई आपसे ये नहीं लेंगे वो
नहीं लेंगे सब कुछ बताओ मेरी पढ़ाई अच्छी
नहीं लगती तो वो भी बताओ इधर भी चेंज कर
देंगे अगर आपको अगर कुछ और भी चीज आपको
चाहिए की आपको इन चीजों के बड़े में समझना
है वो भी बताओ एकदम सब कुछ हम लोग
एक्सेप्ट करते हैं सो गैस बाय टाटा